hey youtubers its charlie Merry
Christmas so I thought it'd be fun to do
some more Star Wars Easter eggs so I
know I was gonna do a kylo Ren video so
I'll start with some kylo ren's specific
Easter eggs she was careful for spoilers
from the movie if you haven't seen it
yet and the ticket giveaway is still
going on all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video it's just to IMAX gift
certificates so some of these are taken
from the expanded material in the
cross-section books that they've been
releasing as part of the journey to the
force awakens so if you bought some of
these books or you listen to the audio
dramas some of these might sound
familiar
so a really big one first kylo Ren's
lightsaber the reason why it requires
vents is because the lightsaber itself
can contain the energy because it's
built based on a cracked Kyber crystal
so because it's cracked that's why the
blade itself looks like it vibrates
unlike Rey who's using Anakin
Skywalker's original lightsaber which is
built perfectly based on Jedi
specifications the cool thing about
Kyber crystals is that they're very
powerful but this one is cracked so very
clearly it could blow up at any minute
just like kylo ren's personality the
lightsaber design itself is supposed to
be a thousand years old going back to
the scourge of Malachor second big when
kylo ren's mask the reason why it looks
very reflective like it's a very solid
surface compared to Vader's mask which
which had a lot of ridges it had two
separate holes for the eyes kylo ren's
is mostly meant to reflect back a lot of
the stuff that's coming at him so he's
in a sense trying to reflect Vader's
personality it's a big personality think
just like the lightsaber very unstable
very unfinished very unsure of himself
there's ribbing on other people's
personalities other people's lightsaber
designs makes big one this actually make
you a little bit upset so it turns out
that Han Solo is the one that left Leia
like left their marriage because of what
happened to Ben turns out if you read
the novel you find out that Leia learned
about what was happening with been with
Snoke trying to turn him to the dark
side she wanted to handle it on her own
and was not able to
so therefore Han Solo kind of blames
Leia for what happened to Ben maybe if
they had made trying to save him for
turning to the dark side a group effort
they might have been able to stop it
turns out kylo Ren himself is about
thirty years old he was born within
about a year of the Battle of Endor and
then han and Leia were married about
that time so it turns out they were
married for quite a period of time
before Ben turned to the dark side
because it sound like that didn't happen
he was in his teenage years so they
would have had to have been married and
you had this happy family for at least
about 15 years but remember Leia sent
Ben away to train with Luke so like she
wasn't around him the whole time next
big one not necessarily about the
Knights of Ren but about snow training
darkside acolytes turns out kylo Ren is
not his first apprentice but he says
that he is his best because he started
out as a light side Jedi but most of his
previous apprentices were like Darth
Maul they were always dark side force
users the quote from the book talks
about you know kylo Ren being this
fallen Jedi so the quote goes it's far
more than that it's where you were from
what you are made of the dark side and
the light the finest sculptor cannot
fashion a masterpiece from poor
materials he must have something pure
something strong something unbreakable
with which to work so he just said you
know kylo Ren started out on the light
side then came to the dark it's much
easier for Snoke to sculpt a master from
that clay than from just a pure dark
side user the next one's a little bit
more funny it's it's kind of a riff on a
joke from a new hope where Han Solo says
careful droids don't pull people's arms
out of their sockets when they lose well
turns out in the original cut of the
force awakens it was just really bloody
cantina scene where Chewbacca actually
does rip out someone's arms it turns out
unkar plutt here the traitor that Rey
kept trading scraps to who wanted to
steal the droid from her chases are down
to mas kanata's cantina and shooting
that's where Chewbacca rips his arms out
of his sockets so Simon Pegg got his
arms ripped out of his sockets you can
understand why they didn't want a really
bloody scene like that in this pg-13
movie but actually another kylo Ren one
here so JJ Abrams has actually kind of
put forth a different interpretation of
the character based on what he does to
Han Solo
so I'll just say spoiler warning again I
said it at the beginning of the video
but in case you missed it spoilers for
what happens to kylo Ren at the end of
the movie so here we go
JJ Abrams says that what he did to Han
Solo killing Han Solo was kind of like
saying the character has no more good
left in him but in the book and like the
book version that was based on an
earlier version of the script kylo Ren
goes away from that feeling bad about
killing his father so I actually like
that interpretation a little bit more
like he is conflicted he kills Han Solo
so that's all he feels he needs to do to
cut off the pull of the light side of
the force but he still feels bad about
it after the fact
obviously the trilogy is gonna be
more complicated than just being this
simple Redemption arc for kylo Ren but I
do feel like it's gonna be in there
somewhere
bring Ben home know the big pop point I
know everybody's wondering about r2d2
seemingly just miraculously wakes up at
the end of the movie with like the whole
map like oh my god I was to sleep this
whole time well it turns out in the
novel it's because bb-8 wheels up to r2
with his piece of the map and says look
I have this piece of the map do you have
anything to complete it and that's what
wakes r2 up it's not like some crazy
explanation with Luke using the force
from the other side of the galaxy it's
just simply bb-8 with his piece of the
map JJ Abrams has also said how he's cut
a lot of dialogue like Lauren's cast and
was like you don't need all that just
cut the dialogue trust the characters
well part of that was another callback
to Episode four with you know Princess
Leia saying help me obi-wan you're my
only hope they had a moment like that
with Ray and Luke so you can understand
why they cut that it's just way too
on-the-nose and you kind of get that
without them having to say it Luke has a
pretty solid idea why she's tracked him
down now the big r2d2 Easter egg so
turns out he got maps like the the big
map that he has at the end is maps of
all the Jedi temples all over the galaxy
Luke Luke was trying to find the first
one so that's why r2 so important when
they were on the original Death Star he
downloaded all that information because
Darth Vader the Emperor they had
information on where all the Jedi were
hiding so naturally they would keep a
database of that so r2 was able to steal
that that's how Luke got the information
so once again even though you know you
don't see him a lot in the movie r2 is
one of the most important characters
because he has so much information let
me know in the comments though do you
guys actually want them to try and visit
some of those other Jedi temples or do
you think it's gonna be like a minor
plot point it sounds like it's just
gonna be a story thing like they're not
gonna actually travel around and visit
all these Jedi temples but probably my
most fun Easter eggs is the tauntaun
sleeping bag that Rey sleeps in like she
sleeps in an 8080 sleeping bag just like
the tauntaun so just more gas that's
wrong the Luke Skywalker daughter flames
and another really fun lightsaber one is
when she has the vision like it
hallucinates in the floor changes and
you see those panels light up that's the
exact same hallway design from when Luke
Skywalker went to confront Vader for the
very first time so the takeaway is that
the lightsaber is showing her old
memories and places that the lightsaber
has been that she has
not been but what's gonna happen is
there's a whole bunch of other Easter
there's probably hundreds of Easter eggs
that nobody has found yet so I'll
continue to do Easter Egg videos as I
find new stuff but I'll be doing a
couple more Star Wars bonus videos this
weekend so be sure to subscribe to get
everything there is a whole bunch of
footage that just dropped there's like
there's new trailers for arrow legends
of tomorrow there's even more new flash
footage and new Deadpool and new Doctor
Who so I'll post an updated video
scheduled on Christmas morning because
there's like a whole bunch of stuff I
won't be able to do it all in the same
day but I'll get to it like in the next
two days so I'll just I'll post the
schedule tomorrow well I guess wait for
everything to post you can click here
for my first Easter eggs video about all
the cameos all the special cameos in the
movie and you can click here for the
latest Deadpool teaser trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight